there you go your house is on fire
we don't break case of wine I don't mess
around like we used to do [__]
it's Tuesday night it's voodoo night
understand me
but behind those stars literally
he's over there squadron making believe
Hank - that's what we will see with the
tons of the rich it takes you 20 minutes
to eat 10 [__] stars I'm here in 30
minutes but you have to do them premium
Jeep stay on periscope of the 20 [__]
minutes of your time
people think I'm crazy
what's the matter with you boy
it's that type of night [__]
uncle Joey is back and black Tuesday
night we got a little podcast going on
tonight you're not doing that in any way
you [__] mooks get your [__] together
go steal your uncle's cough medicine
we're going deep tonight you understand
me if you're under 18 don't worry we'll
call medicine is go play with [__]
Barney Rubble or something [__]
uncle Joey's back [__] we're here for
another fun-filled evening it's 4/20
month so if you ain't sparking get off
now Lee don't make believe you throwing
those stars away [__] I'm watching you
like a [__] security guard at CVS you
understand those little Chinese gods
they sit upstairs and they watch it on
the computer
meanwhile you think you got away with
that [__] brush get your life
together you [__] amateur oh [__]
Rolling Stones some girls keeps riches
throwing heat like a [__]
[__] head well what would I like
all these people celebrate before 20
listen for 20s every day my [__]
world understand me and then eight in
your world turn off this [__] right now
and go watch Star Wars and may believe
you're a [__] Martian or whatever the
[__] you want uncle Joey's back oh [__]
420 in Oxnard let's do this [__] do this
[__] do this [__] do this [__] you guys
are looking beautiful tonight admission
I work today I'm working tomorrow and
then it's all over it's blue cheese or
go [__] your mother in the [__] a
hammer and [__] does if you eat ranch
dressing you got hemorrhoids you
understand me
don't come crying to me how do I know it
took the survey anyway leave you ready
for a bong in the debt we're gonna open
up strong me stars you got left for
don't belie than me Jay for you through
to
I know I watch a lot right they're not
in your pockets you threw them over
there in the corner
check my pocket see that's how I know
well yeah I'm in your socks this [__] be
a nice little pocket here get the party
started
hey believe me tightly [__] what the
[__] just Fagin la oh [__]
Mick Jagger's throwing some eat tonight
look it's all fun with the beer let's do
this let's go soldier you're not time to
play games burn that thing are you
kidding me or what you understand me
I got this weed from Bangkok from a
little guy in a bicycle with a t-shirt
on that's it
we don't [__] around hit the church I've
been telling you [__] for [__]
years this ain't no amateur show this
ain't no [__] Michael Jackson and this
ain't thrill of [__] you
understand me uncle Joey here in full
effect which I got your back that's all
that matters
on a Tuesday night you're sitting there
was my next move get a bomb get a
notebook and we'll [__] plan the
attack understand
oh [__] are you [__] kidding me alive
are you kidding me or what Uncle Joe is
here we in I don't know I had a good day
I hope you had a great day too
you know I love your mother [__]
along my heart I want everything to be
smooth leading out one more Bundy coming
ladies we gotta stretch out the lungs
and get you [__] shape for the weekend
I'm gonna give you a big butt and I want
to see you do to fondants with that
thing every night next weakness [__]
in celebration of 4/20 you can't be
[__] around I'm saying if you [__]
around you'll be left behind the same
way it happens in life you're over there
giggling having a good time and this guy
got the [__] promotion because you
let's go stand on line and get tickets
get the [__] out of here I'll sit in
this [__] desk so I run this [__]
place you understand me
anyway uncle Joey here how many times
you gotta say that Joey no you [__]
here I'm sitting here 20 [__] minutes
you already told me 10 times your
[__] here you understand me we got a
great show for you tonight
I'm going through changes myself but
they don't let that affect you you I'm
saying it's got nothing to do with the
cat
it's Joey Diaz solo look you're my main
man Lisa out over that fuming from the
gums waiting for another bonnet I told
me you gotta back off this is the [__]
that Pontius pilot smoke Thursday before
he killed Jesus on Friday what's up dog
[Music]
what do you want [__] oh [__] he's
calling me out he says he wants a bond
it will clean this one up good this one
goes right to the [__] that did this
is it we're gonna be polite
[__] I'm gonna see if the
[__] tie guy got another batch of
this refund you should have seen how it
came packaged I never seen nothing like
that in my life
look at you look at you trying to tell
me you a 20 started I got the FBI
analyzing that tape right now and
they're starting to find glitches if
anybody can find the glitch in a video
is the FBI trust me if they put the
glitches in they know how to take a look
who the [__] you think you're dealing
with you gotta know people on the inside
anyway
when was the listen to the [__]
stones like nobody's [__] in the room
you know say they don't give a [__] when
the whip comes down you understand me
they don't give a [__] when the whit
look who comes up with those type of sex
you ready go you're gonna change some
changes physical bum I'm ready
[Music]
this is what they give you before you
cut your leg off in the army right here
they give you here is [__]
here we go here we go tiny little bong
hits
you shouldn't saying but like I told you
people when I go to the [__] weed
store I get [__] the smoke at night
I got personal little friends that
they're [__] professional heads they
smoked so much pot they lost their
hearing understand me that's the kind of
[__] we get you want to come or hang
with the Voodoo Lounge you got to show
up with a [__] backpack let's do this
[__] you don't need one [__]
that's how stone that was painful water
in the park that's it in the stay a
little comfy
[Music]
they know the Wawa that'll set you
straight families let's do this mister
strength
[Music]
they don't play though that's what other
guy that's something about there you go
that's the one that's the one cheap
that's the one right there that's the
training right you some saying I proved
my point
he shows up being eats 11 ain't 11:25
one you had thought you had a [__]
sack yet who sacks
why what are you saving for the
apocalyptic [__] take over stars I
don't stop til they're [__] done
understand me you know me we start we
start in the morning that's why I give
them up to light cuz I got problems
you're missin you tell don't have
psychological problems I got [__]
problem you know you got problems you
got other type of problems you you ready
go ahead what is safe when he was a kid
you had sugar treating something to a
safe out the window it on the [__]
head he ends up in [__] Laughlin yeah
I'm sayin
only people would I meet you end up in
Laughlin think of the but I know I am
here at the right place okay you got 20
hours come with me ah he's [__] what
do you guys do man yeah come on man with
this all worked out for you what let's
do another bong hit line one up
[__]
I'm telling you tonight's your lucky
night
oh [__] ah snot [__] levity live 420
sponsors by [__] star 1 AKA estrellas
del amor take ah you bad [__]
the savage is still here he's resting
tonight he took the night off doing last
night we put him through the [__]
gauntlet understand me
[Music]
that sitting that's that what time you
got Tarzan oh [__]
just when you thought it was [__]
safe I enjoyed seeing you [__]
I always do you guys know that listen
man I'm a fat [__] I'm all gone I want
that [__] stage goes I only can go out
two weeks a month I'm old man I get too
much anxiety I had [__] yell I scream
I go [__] bananas and speaking of
bananas my girl jessimae Peluso
but being bananas is Fort Lee this month
she's one of my girls she reached out
she knows that's the old neighborhood so
if you get a minute go out there and
check out jessimae Peluso at [__]
bananas you guys are savages up there
from Nyack the white flames to the
boogie down all you [__]
represent it last weekend Bodie was
flunking Dominicans Dominicans dressed
as boutique was it was a fucked-up night
but we all showed up we had a good
[__] time
that's what commies about dawg you know
we bust balls we talk about who gives a
[__] at the end of the day you still
gotta go to shop right pay for your
[__] groceries are you doing over
there when you thought you changes
already
[__] yeah you going through changes
already this is not that type of show
you know I'm saying if you watch this
show we go through changes right and
[__] funny or why because why cover
it up what we're doin anyway what did I
say the helicopter only was Trump's on
the show up with a machine known for
what I'm just a fat [__] with his Jewish
little gold bar we bother no yo with
those couple bonnets [__] shut a
microphone we ain't disrespecting the
flag understanding that's the most
important thing we just respect another
type of people things but never the flag
can you [__] together you understand me
I always want to be a history major one
my Tony is one you get 185 an hour and
let the [__] you anyway
you sure but I was too stupid so I had a
[__] drop back they tell mr. Keith
Richards on this beep into the murky
waters that's heroin guitar right there
you're gonna show up a what a [__]
marshmallow what the [__] wrong would
you get your life together you'll
implant this is it this ain't even
[__] edibles is the money this is
straight-up [__] Rifa through the
heart I love you guys I worked on a set
today cranly on a TV show today and
tomorrow we think you're dealing with
here joy bananas prank telling you [__]
you know wife is out surprising you'll
be watching TV scratching your balls and
band there I'll be in the commercial you
know he told me about that I'm [__]
periscope twice you understand because
what else would you do it yourself
either scratch your balls eat hot dogs
I'm saying once you're out of hot dogs
guys start scratching your balls Lea
that's how I [__] know and that's it
and that's that little [__] Rolling
Stones we're waiting on the guest and
that's it your loan against this you
know [__] tune in youtube.com slash c
/ Joey Diaz how's that feel right off
the top of my [__] head roll it off
your [__] towel [__] what is it
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz to catch
the church was happening now live and in
[__] color alright this one that's
gonna get released until Thursday our
Wednesday night late so you get a chance
to see it
first you follow I'm saying here I need
to get toothpicks in my [__] eyeballs
that's the only way to see you guys we
gotta let that what are you doing who
stays in order on the [__] computer
do me a favor let's invent some [__]
toothpicks for the eyeballs yeah I'm
saying we'll solve a hundred thousand of
those things
well the ends whoever sends the best
picture will send them to a room for
three days and we'll shoot him down
there
he won't never come back like that
battery Holloway whatever [__] barely
halfway went down at a roller skate she
sucked the dick and they stabbed or that
what are you gonna do
god forbid and now that kid don't want
to give her up
he's worse than [__] Charles Mets and
he can give it over you I'll never tell
you where the body is I'm [__]
believable god bless this oh I don't
mean to goof on nobody I'm just telling
you the truth
one minute you [__] in a band
drinking rum the next minute you're in
the beach getting choked you like
together talk something don't trust
nobody keep eyeballs in yet and the back
of your [__] head you understand me
don't trust nobody and come up to you
[__] you I don't know nothing and you
don't say that to me you say it to me
your body language will your eyes [__]
you I don't know nothing you understand
me and you keep [__] walking that's
it you don't know nothing you don't know
that I don't know what a train is I
don't know I'm just the fact the
satellite just dropped me to [__] off I
don't know nothing I'll and it like
Arnold Schwarzenegger in 84 terminated
remember one minute he was naked the
next minute he had a [__] tuxedo on
it happens [__] anyway I love you
[__] youtube.com slash seats last
Joey Diaz
stay black I love you look at this look
at this portrait
BAM you two can have my balls like that
what an enchanted week with uncle Joey
and a beachside resort in North
Hollywood